You can probably see where let
and const are going to be useful,
where you need to scope
something to a block or when you
want to make a variable that
cannot be changed by anyone by
accident or on purpose. Let's
take a look at a couple of more
examples of when it might be
useful. The first one is
replacing the IFFE. I'm not sure
if you've ever heard of this
before, but it was coined by Ben
Allman back in 2010. It's called
the Immediately-Involved
Function Expression. What it
does is it is a function that
runs itself immediately and it
sort of creates a scope where
nothing is going to leak into
the parent scope. In our case,
the global scope of the window.
If I have a variable, just a var
variable, name = Wes. I give it
a refresh and now I type in "
name." It works and that's OK
for the demo here. What you
might not know is that the
window actually has a name
attribute, which is needed when
you have a window opening up a
second window. That's something
that may be some third-party
JavaScript relies on, in order
for it to run, or maybe someone
else has a variable name and you
accidentally overwrite that, and
it starts to get a little bit
messy. The way that they fix
that is you make this thing
called an IFFE, which is a
function that runs immediately
and you put your variables
inside of that. These variables
are now scoped to this function
here, because var variables are
function-scoped, and they are
not available in the global
scope. I type "name" there,
and it's actually not undefined,
it's just blank because that is
a property that lives on the
window natively in JavaScript.
If I needed to access this,
obviously, I'd have to do a
console log inside of here, but
the important thing is that it's
no longer leaking into the
global scope. With let and
const variables, we don't even
need a function for our
variables to be scoped to that.
Because why, let and const are
block scope. Really all you need
to do, we bring this up here and
let's make that a const variable.
Let's make sure that it's going
to give us this global scope
again. Type the name, there we
go. We got "Wes." But if I
were to simply just open and
close a pair of curly brackets,
that is a block, and now it is
going to be scoped to that block.
Refresh this, type in name, you
get the pair of quotes again. If
I wrote a console.log(name)
inside of this, it gives me "Wes."
Pretty cool. You don't need any
of that IFFE stuff anymore.
You're using let and const
because they are going to be
scoped to that block. The
other problem using let and
const will fix is with our for
loop. This is something that you
probably have all run into with
your regular for loop. Now, I
just go ahead and console.log(i),
and we should see that we get
zero through nine. Problems
that arise here are two things.
First of all, if I type "i" into
the console, you'll see that it
is 10. We have this global
variable that has leaked out and
is leaked into either the window
or into our parent scope which
is not something we necessarily
want. That's just a placeholder
value that we need to work
inside of this loop. Second
of all, is let's say you were
doing something inside of this
loop. Maybe you had something
that's going to run after some
bit of time, an AJAX request or
I'm going to mark it up with a
setTimeout(). I'm going to say
setTimeout(). We have a function
here and that function is going
to run after one second.
After one second, let's do
console.log, the number is...
We'll put the i variable inside
of there. It's going to run
after a second. That's weird.
After a second, all of them are
10. The reason that we have that
is because, right here, console.
log(i), that will run
immediately and reference
whatever i is. That runs
immediately at console log
itself. However, after one
second, this entire loop has
already gone through every
iteration that it needs to and
the variable i, here, is being
overwritten every single time.
The problem with that is that by
the time the first setTimeout()
runs, the i variable is already
at 10, and we don't have any way
to reference it. Similarly,
if you had like an AJAX request
where you are looping through
them, there's no real good way
other than using an IFFE to
reference what that i variable
was at the time of running, not
at the current time. One
quick way we canfix that is if
we just change var to let. What
do we know about let? Let is
block-scoped. Look at that this!
This is a block scope, so our
variables are now going to be
scoped to here. I rerun this.
There we go. After a second,
zero through nine. We're not
getting 10, 10 times. We getting
it as it was declared each and
every time. You can't use a
const for that because it will
overwrite itself. You can't
assign the same variable twice.
When we use let, it's going to
scope that i variable right to
our curly brackets here.